[Music]
my
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats our program will begin shortly
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats the program will begin shortly
[Music]
baby
[Music]
my
beauty
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
oh
[Music]
start tweeting
i got a piano now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states accompanied by the
vice president of the united states and
miss michelle duster
[Music]
foreign
everybody
all right
[Applause]
points
thank you
a little unusual to do the bill signing
not say anything and then speak but uh
that's how we set it up
ladies and gentlemen
good afternoon
i just signed into law
the emmett till anti-lynching act
making lynching
a federal hate crime
for the first time in american history
i want to thank vice president harris
who was a key co-sponsor this bill when
she was the united states senator
[Music]
[Applause]
and i also want to thank speaker pelosi
and leader schumer members of the
congress here today especially
congressman hoyer bobby rush senator
dick durbin and corey booker
i
i also want to thank senator tim scott
who couldn't be here today
and the civil rights leaders gather here
today and most of all the family of
emmett till and i to b wells
thank you for never giving up
never ever giving up
matter of fact granddaughter told me
that
her
mother was here when
on your grandmother's hair when 1898 in
1898
in order to make a case for
the anti-lynching law
it was over a hundred years ago in 1900
north carolina representative george
henry white the son of a slave the only
black lawmaker in congress at the time
who first introduced legislation to make
lynching a federal crime
hundreds hundreds of similar bills have
failed to pass
over the years
several federal hate crime laws were
enacted including one i signed last year
to combat covert 19 hate crimes but no
federal law
no federal law expressly prohibited
lynching none
until today
[Applause]
one of the leading chronicles of our
history of the lynching is brian
stevenson who happens to be delawarean
from our home state who wanted very much
to be here today but he could not
he helped build a national memorial for
peace and justice in montgomery alabama
america's first site dedicated to
understanding the legacy of lynching
you know his extensive research showed
that between
1877
and 1950 more than 4
400.
black people were murdered by lynching
most in the south but some in the north
as well
that's a lot of folks man and a lot of
silence for a long time
lynching was pure terror to enforce the
lie
that not everyone not everyone belongs
in america not everyone is created equal
terror to systematically undermine
hard-fought civil rights
terror
not just in the dark of the night but in
broad daylight
innocent men women and children hung by
nooses from trees
bodies burned and drowned and
castrated
their crimes
trying to vote
trying to go to school
trying to own a business or preach the
gospel
false accusations of murder arson and
robbery
simply being black
often the crowds of white families
gather to celebrate the spectacle taking
pictures of the bodies and mailing them
as postcards
emmett till was an only child
he grew up in the south side of chicago
with his mother mamie and grandparents
and cousins
in the summer of 1955
emmett turned 14 years old ready to
start eighth grade in the fall
before school started he wanted to visit
his cousins in mississippi
samus mom dropped him off at the train
station in chicago
her own family fled the delta decades
earlier so she told him she told him the
unwritten rules she had to follow quote
be very careful how you speak
say yes sir and no ma'am and do not
hesitate to be to humble yourself if you
have to get down on your knees end of
quote
that same speech
that same admonition
too many black parents today still have
to use that admonition
they have to tell their children when it
comes to encounters with the law
enforcement
you know and so many other circumstances
she kissed emma goodbye
was the last time she saw her son alive
days after he arrived in mississippi
emmett's mutilated body was found in the
river
barbed wire
tied around his neck
and a 75 pound cotton gin fan
attached that wire as he's thrown into
the river
emma's mother
his mother demanded that her son be sent
home
so this funeral in chicago could be an
open casket
here's what she said
let the people see what i've seen
america and the world saw what she saw
emmett till was born nearly 40 years ago
after the first annihilation law was
introduced
although he was one of thousands who
were lynched his mother couraged his
mother's courage to show the world what
was done to him
energized the civil rights movement
exactly 100 days later rosa parks was
arrested on the bus in montgomery
her statue sits in my office
she said i thought of emmett till and i
couldn't go back
i thought of emmett till and i couldn't
go back
dr king often preached about quote the
crying voices of little emmett till
screaming from the rushes of the
mississippi
to the till family
we remain in awe of your courage
to find purpose
through your pain
to find purpose for your pain
but the law is not just about the past
it's about the present
and our future as well
from the bullets
in the back of
ahmad aubry
to countless other acts of violence
countless victims known and unknown
the same racial hatred that drove the
mob to hang a noose
brought that mob carrying torches out of
the fields of charlottesville
just a few years ago
racial hate isn't an old problem
it's a persistent problem
a persistent problem
and i know many of the civil rights
leaders you know you heard me say it a
hundred times
hate never goes away
it only hides
it hides under the rocks
given just a little bit of oxygen
it comes roaring back out
screaming
but what stops it
is all of us not a few
all of us have to stop it
people like ida b wells one of the
founders of the naacp established a
hundred years ago in response to racial
terror across the country
a brilliant gifted writer
she exposed the barbaric nature of
lynching
as a tool to intimidate and subjugate
black americans
and her words
her courage her convictions
she was trying to prevent the murders of
emmett till
and lamont arbory
so many others
over 4 400 others
ida bill i to be well once said quote
the way to right wrongs
is to turn the light of truth upon the
wrongs
turn the light of truth
upon the wrongs
that's what all of you have done
gathered in this rose garden
with this bill and so much more
including i to b wells's great
granddaughter
michelle duster whom i'm honored to
introduce
to mark this historic day michelle
welcome to the white house and welcome
to the podium as my mother would say god
love you dear
all right i didn't see you i'm sorry
i'm going to just take a moment to take
in this
because it has been a very long time
thank you president biden for that
introduction and for your leadership
in signing this bill into law
my brother dan and i are honored to be
here and represent our great grandmother
ida b wallace barnett
who once said
our country's national crime is lynching
she was born enslaved in 1862 holly
springs mississippi
the same state where fourteen-year-old
hemet till was lynched 93 years later
she became one of the first
investigative and most prominent
journalist and civil rights activist of
her time
she carefully chronicled names
dates locations and excuses
used to justify lynchings
she wrote articles and pamphlets and
gave speeches about the atrocities
and it was personal to her
because three of her enterprising
friends
thomas moss will stewart
and calvin mcdowell
who co-owned a grocery store in memphis
were lynched in 1892.
she knew these upstanding men who were
leaders in the community they were
guilty of no crime
through her writing and speaking she
exposed uncomfortable truths that upset
the status quo
truth that lynching was being used as an
excuse
to terrorize the black community in
order to maintain a social and economic
hierarchy
based on race
and for that
her life was threatened
her printing press was destroyed and she
was exiled from the south
despite losing everything
she continued to speak out across this
country and great britain about the
violence and terror of lynching
she eventually settled in chicago where
i was born
and where emmett till was born
and in 1898 in response to the lynching
of postmaster fraser baker
in lake city south carolina
she visited president william s mckinley
right here
in washington to urge him to make
lynching a federal
crime since my great-grandmother's visit
to the white house
124 years ago
there have been over 200 attempts to get
legislation enacted
and 17 years ago in 2005
my brother dan
spoke at the senate press conference
where they issued an apology for not
passing the legislation
but we
finally stand here today
generations later
to witness this historic moment of
president biden
signing the emmett till anti-lynching
bill into law
[Applause]
we are here today because of the
tenacity of the civil rights leaders and
commitment of members of congress
who are here today
and because of someone who was
instrumental in this bill when she was a
senator
and someone my great-grandmother would
especially be proud of
it is my humble honor to introduce the
vice president of the united states
kamala harris
[Applause]
all good
good afternoon everyone good afternoon
michelle thank you for your powerful
words i was so glad that we had some
time
uh in the oval office with the president
to talk with you about the historic day
that we are celebrating but on the
shoulders of so many including your
family and you who have written about it
maintaining your family's legacy
of speaking truth always so thank you
it's good to see everybody president
biden members of congress have to shout
out to the cbc
um to my fellow americans thank you all
so lynching
well it we know it's a stain on the
history of our nation
since our founding and in particular
in the century following the civil war
thousands of people in states across our
nation
were tortured
and murdered
by vigilantes
they were dragged from their homes
they had ropes
wrapped around their necks
they were hanged
burned drowned
and dismembered
often as the president said as their
families were forced to watch
and as crowds gathered
to spectate
these lynchings were motivated of course
by racism
and meant to cause terror
they were acts committed to secure
political and social control
but they were not designated crimes by
the federal government
lynching
was not considered a crime
by the federal government
legislation to make lynching a federal
crime was first introduced in the united
states congress
in the year 1900
it failed
in the 122 years since
anti-lynching legislation has been
introduced to the united states congress
more than 200 times
advanced by leaders such as james weldon
johnson of the naacp
and of course
the phenomenal ida b wells
who courageously
knew what had to be done and were
undeterred
and when we speak of ida b wells
let's understand
the courageous
nature of that incredible american
who used her skill her profession her
calling as a journalist
as president biden noted to help open
the eyes of our nation
to the terror of lynching which speaks
of course to the role that we have known
also historically i'm going off script
for a moment about the importance of the
black press
and the importance of making sure that
we have the storytellers always in our
community who we will support to tell
the truth when no one else is willing to
tell it
[Applause]
and so those heroes who petitioned every
president from mckinley
to hoover to support federal legislation
anti-lynching legislation was introduced
in the wake of some of these most brutal
attacks
after the murder of mary turner in 1918
after the murder of emmett till in 1955
and james byrd jr in 1998
and james craig anderson in 2011.
and it failed again and again
and again
and again
anti-lynching legislation was
reintroduced
in the united states congress
by leaders
who understood that our past
must not and cannot
be forgotten that the truth must be
spoken no matter how difficult it is to
speak
and certainly no matter how difficult it
is to hear
leaders who understood that the victims
of lynching and their families
and all of our society
deserve that we recognize the crimes
and the injustice
of what was occurring
and that the people of our nation
deserve the protection
of a federal a federal anti-lynching law
when i served in the united states
senate it was a profound honor to
sponsor with cory booker
the emmett till anti-lynching act and i
want to say a thing about cory booker
i'm going to talk about him in front of
his face
cory booker i have had the privilege of
working with
and he is a man of uncommon courage
unmatched moral clarity
and an unwavering commitment to doing
what is right thank you cory booker
and i also want to recognize and thank
senator tim scott whose partnership of
course helped us pass this legislation
and with congressman bobby rush
there you are
who kept this fight alive for so many
years in the united states congress
congressman rush
you have dedicated your career to
guiding our nation toward justice and i
thank you
and thank you to so many other leaders
who are gathered here who helped us
reach this very important day
leaders who witnessed the brutal reality
of lynching such as ollie gordon
and reverend wheeler parker cousins of
emmett till
for whom the stories of these crimes are
not lines in a history book
but vivid memories
so today we are gathered to do
unfinished business
to acknowledge the horror
in this part of our history
to state unequivocally that lynching is
and has always been a hate crime
and to make clear
that the federal government may now
prosecute these crimes as such
lynching
is not a relic of the past
racial acts of terror still occur in our
nation
and when they do we must all have the
courage to name them
and hold the perpetrators to account
[Applause]
and with that i'll close by saying this
i believe that so often
and it has been said
the victims of lynching were targeted
and let's be clear about this
because they were working to build a
better america
that's what they were doing
it was in everybody's best interest what
they were doing
but unfortunately the cowards couldn't
see
didn't understand
those folks
who were killed they were business
owners
creating economic opportunity in their
community by which all would prosper and
benefit
they were teachers
educating the next generation of
america's leaders
they were activists
who were defending the sacred freedom to
vote
so today as we recognize them as we
recognize our history
let us also be here gathered
to recommit ourselves
to that unfinished business as well
to continuing to fight for freedom
for opportunity
and justice
for all may god bless you and may god
bless america thank you all
[Music]
know
[Music]
all the cabinet
[Applause]
way up
and all the members of the house and
senate please stand
all right
okay well thank you everybody very much
this is a uh
as someone once said this is a big deal
this is a big deal
so thank you thank you thank you
appreciate it all thank you
come on over here and get it
[Music]
look
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
ah
do you think
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
it
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay
very happy
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
they don't want her though
[Music]
[Music]
is
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hello
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
she's
[Music]
[Music]
let's get
yes
[Music]